hey there reject nation Greg Albee here
I'm John so uh it's probably going up a
significantly later than the time we're
actually shooting this act we uploaded a
couple hours ago our Avengers 4 trailer
reaction which featured an opening
sketch and there being a lot longer than
we thought I wrote it came over like
it's probably like two minutes put it
together my code is like almost five
whole minutes or to make moments hit
tune work he's looking forward to seeing
what the response and I'm seeing the
response and it's pretty funny because
when we started doing the sketches for
but to play before reactions or to start
off super short one was like Justice
League which was like a twenty second
bit and then we did one for Star Wars
last Jedi and it evolved into the
infinity war one which became really
popular videos yeah they went from being
bits into being actual schedule then
when the movie roofer Infinity Ward was
coming around we were like yeah I was
like come with the sketches and I came
up with one there being like five
minutes long and so now it's like a
vendor's really people expect to sketch
a lot of the time they probably don't
want it as long as this especially when
it's a reaction but you know I feel like
overall we've got it like a 94 Friday I
did the math like a 94% like so yeah
it's going well and late to the party
are people that we know and we didn't
reveal what the whole sketch was about
were like we just need you to do this
one moment basically there's gonna be a
montage of like people disappearing you
do this one shot for us just so we can
have it in the modern I didn't tell him
what the sketch was going on what really
happens in it and they shot a reaction
to it so you know so reaction we could
talk more about you know them into
sketch or whatever afterwards let's get
meta reaction reacts up should guys are
good peeps amazing Schmoe down
competitors good people hung out with
them quite a bit I love these guys
[Music]
and great angel rejects decided that
they wanted to do something special for
their Avengers reaction definitely be
part of it so I'm looking forward to
they just Texas this morning regarding
this skip the date day saying that it's
been uploaded so I'm looking forward to
sitting I know there's a couple of other
reactors in there so I want to see yeah
because they put forth to get this intro
put together we were just a small cog in
the giant machine that is the reject
nation
[Music]
intro to the real rejects reaction to
Avengers this is what I like watching
reactions when it's our stuff yeah the
rare time that actually happens maybe
that's where the dislikes came almost
work
[Music]
in 1987 so Cornelia delay I like the two
minutes of retrieve your finger eyes if
you're really looking hey you notice
roads
[Music]
come back to what I was half worried if
people would remember the first sketch
[Laughter]
our first channel the first sequel
sketch ever her dad so we had to go
bigger
[Music]
[Music]
we got a funny card about that how you
solve it I'll tell you guys it is sick
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
it's not easy
she's directing it acting simultaneously
and being a bunch of the other
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that was great
reject nation you guys have definitely
some awesome leading the way put you
through everybody beat Grace Randolph as
well to the
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ha good cut there yeah yeah I've always
liked Robert and Vanessa because when we
first started doing like reactions all
the real rejects wasn't really like a
bunch of commentary after reaction
I felt like we start off doing review so
it'd be nice to provide more commentary
and I feel like in the general medium it
was like that where most people just
kind of react and say subscribe but it's
funny about the reaction community is
that most people click off if you look
at watch time after a reaction is that
most people already clicked off already
they tend to that's just the way it goes
99% of the time really likes to give
like feedback and opinions do editing
and whatever Robert and Vanessa always
like their commentary like they've
always had good reactions but their
commentary something I've always
appreciated so and and their commentary
really shows that they know they're
talking about when you see them compete
on their own a know they compete on the
Schmo down you're like wow you've
probably seen more movies than I could
ever it's very impressive stuff we were
doing all this work to get the reactors
to do the moment of when they fade
there's really not a lot of work for
them it's by simple but to explain it
sounds like so complex that everyone got
their footage to us so late they got us
like very anxious like I really get this
montage in here
it's not gonna work without the montage
yeah yeah yeah well yeah it's like the
centerpiece of everything and especially
when we thought the trailer might be
dropping last week yeah no way this is
gonna happen the yeah all we have to do
all they have to do is just we needed we
call it like a plate so you just get a
background whether or not on the shot
then you could pin up a green screen and
then and then sit oh and the frame where
you need to be at but barely any
movement or if you don't have a green
screen you can just sit in front of the
background pretty much everyone except
effects yeah Wendy was the only one who
had a green screen when he had Dustin
which it really helped out because Kyle
did the VFX it was much easier for him
to do that with a green screen but ya
know they were the first ones to get
their stuff to us which was very much
appreciated because like he said he
really they did 10-minute tape we were
like really just need a few seconds you
know they take a minute of your time
like going over to my brother jammies
like we both might even think you need
this you need this like I know why
people take it to take a long time to
get back to us cuz it seems like it's
gonna be this like really long task when
it's not yeah yeah yeah whatever fun
e-enough like we got a bunch of footage
in from aqus on and that became like the
nicest little happy accident cuz that
little sequence was good but it needed
some kind of contrast and then we found
that just random moment of him oh yeah
yeah like looking and stuff cuz Kyle are
the guy who who says I lied in here a
fan Theory Channel I'm gonna be in a
Marvel movie and he was on vacation and
the aqua song got his footage to us last
and it was like gosh I really don't want
to ask Paula do it's crashing on you
and then looking at Augusta's let us
like ten minutes of footage he said just
a lot of options
yogi sounds like a funny body language
about him like he's got oh he's got a
funny way of moving and then there was
this like snippet of a moment that just
seemed like funny if he was the only one
he's a little contrast not everyone
deserves because a lot of this was
mistakes that we kind of worked with
like I told Tyrone the wrong line
because he was opposed to say the dr.
strange line yeah there was no other way
I had him say it was the only way it was
the only way you know be funny if it
were just like a snippet of a poem and
the line here at the bottom yeah you do
Commodore that we got the line wrong
well that's the magic of a lot of the
especially these little sketches because
they're always sort of like okay where
can we wedge in sometimes and so a lot
of the magic comes out of those little
happy accidents and stuff like that or
those challenges that you have to figure
out creative solutions to there were a
lot of those on this and funny enough
watching it back here made me just
appreciate what is to be appreciated
about reaction videos in general because
especially what is your thing your body
people react to it it's easy to want to
actually like talk back yeah like oh
yeah this thing alright you know I just
enjoyed watching you guys watch our
little Dana you guys we partly wanted to
celebrate the fact of how so many people
do reactions for these things in 10
because then any of the people who watch
us tend to watch other reactors as well
one even like with the Avengers movies
we'll put out compilations of people's
read exactly for the first infinity war
trailer before the trailer ever came out
there was a compilation of people
reacting so I thought like it would be
funny do our own spin on it
the decimating effect was the very
popular thing that went on and the MCU
so it would be funny to do that with the
reactors and all of us have that anxiety
moment of we got to get our reaction of
so be fun to play on that and yeah I
know it ended up longer than I would
have liked it to have been but I'm like
you know it's a combination movie it's a
sequel sketch to a sketch that people
probably don't even really remember that
well it's gotta go bigger and plus
I don't know how mad can you be when we
got like a pretty I think a pretty good
job on those decimation you did X I'm
Ian those clouds look great look great
we worked our ass off on it and it was a
lot of editing to put into it
I like the cost of your like so cringe
is I'm like it's part of the or the
reason to be a little corny we're taking
this way too seriously
scene is not supposed to be like this
like super serious moment sounds like
matic short for like great acting here
going for a good-enough gonna be serious
enough to create commodore cheese that a
great sound thank you guys for watching
this late to the party you guys and
thank you to all who liked and watched
our video as well you guys can subscribe
too late to the party go check them out
of Suzy cannon before we wrap this video
up I'll give a page of the day shout out
to a man named Tyler hey Tyler hey did
Google hang out with you not long ago
buddy a friend from Wisconsin a little
special treatment we gave for him was
because he gave us a ps4 Pro and you
know it was my birthday and he sent us
one out of nowhere and it was very very
delightful it's the only reason I can
play Red Dead Redemption 2 now because
they came with Red Dead Redemption - it
was a bundle pack Thank You Tyler for
that and and then I was like you know
what I'm gonna show him this sketch yeah
I don't want it I wanted to be a
surprise for everyone you know how
people were doing a sketch and knew that
if the sketch was long so that's why I
would sometimes give heads up that we're
doing a sketch when we talked about it
that way people weren't so thrown for a
loop even though plenty of people
happened but Tyler we got to see his
reaction is just lively and oh nice
seeing his reaction because it's such a
delightful smile like comforting yeah
I'm vibe you know a very pleasant
disposition a nice face so Tyler I love
you buddy
Merry Christmas Eve jolly old friend of
ours man love the hell out of you yeah
subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification bell and check us on
patreon we got TV show reaction watch
along skew and A's he does music video
coverage would love to have you become a
patron jerk today